do you have a electric car yet like an
EV Tesla or anything I'm going to come
out with my own car so how's your car
really come out with my own car How's
that gonna have like is this already is
this something that's real or are you
just saying it sometimes I feel like you
just be saying [__] I mean just it is it
this ain't this is this idea that I have
okay said that right now yeah okay but
you want to do a soldier card hey come
on man tell my electric car I was like
come on man but I like to touch a little
got the Bit TV screen do you have a
Tesla
I got no Tesla man I like I gotta I like
like hellcats like I got the Hellcat
like I want to go fast I wanna I wanna
hear it you know but I like it though it
looked good right and you know stuff
like that it was just kind of slow but
did you see the Tesla's slow it's slow
which what
do you know that the test was the
fastest car that anybody can buy in the
United States then a Lamborghini yeah
it'll smoke the Tesla Model S plaid will
smoke when I talk about Tesla Model flat
we just want the regular Tesla I'm
telling you they're smoking on
Lamborghini man what okay listen the
Tesla Model S plaid yes it's 140 000
West is not Model S play at all Tesla
models can smoke a Lamborghini that's
what you tell I would say half of them
okay cool fix it half a model X and a
Model S well not all alone come on man
you're not telling me I might roll in
the wrong Tesla though you know what I'm
saying it was DJ Vlad Tesla I don't know
that [__] was slow it might have been
the right time wait first of all you're
hanging out with Vlad again it was a
long time ago it was a long time ago
that's what to say people even had me in
the Tesla that [__] was slow as [__] I
was like what the [__] I gotta go fast
what was the car ride like with you and
DJ Vlad in the Tesla he's like what
soldier the car could drive itself oh
I'm like man watch out with this [__]
when are you gonna make your Triumph of
return to Vlad
I don't know for you know I'm gonna put
up on them I ain't sure are you guys
good now hell no
I'm full of them on them though we gonna
talk though you know I'm saying get a
little interview done I feel like it's
it's like
it also could be very
um I feel like he'd probably throw you a
bag every three weeks to do an interview
like he does with boozy he I don't want
his money man yeah everything ain't
about the money sometimes just like
respect principles [__] like yeah like
morals you know what I'm saying I got
three Styles bro I can make money yeah I
can walk out of here and make however
much money I want right now you know I
appreciate that everybody
trying to pay me trying to bribe me to
talk to you like get the [__] out of
here most artists would not have your
approach well that's why I [__] with you
bro for so what would you do I did hear
that you recently okay because I don't
think people understand as an artist
that you do private gigs sometimes
sometimes you do stuff for like uh oh
yeah like a uh maybe a bar mitzvah or
you go and do something for like a tech
company yeah I heard recently well maybe
not too recent
that you had like a crazy show you did
in San Francisco was it for a tech
company or was it like a it was
something I'd be doing it was like a
private event but you got bagged out how
often are you getting like the private
event bags that we don't even hear about
that'd be coming a lot you know what I'm
saying I do a lot of regular shows I got
the tour coming up but then you're right
I do a lot of stuff that people can't
even get into and people don't even have
you ever done a bar mitzvah yeah what
was that like it was crazy it was like
like you said it was a bag they got
money I'm like hey y'all got money like
that to be paying for that like wow how
many songs did you have to do I was like
two three that's it yeah that's amazing
yeah bar mitzvahs I'm the best them the
biggest bags
I'm the biggest bags just go and do a
bar mitzvah clean up do two or three
songs eat the free food be on your way
a 100 but y'all get the tickets I'm
going on tour though Soldier world uh in
August I'm doing soldier World in August
30 30 plus Days by 40 days okay
um we're going everywhere who are you
going out with just I mean have you
gotten this is my first headline until
you know saying my first two I did it
was me Chris Brown Bow Wow second tour
was this your first headlining tour of
your car myself for my whole career wow
because you go back and look at all my
tools you see me on tour people you see
me with Wayne you see me with gz you see
me with bow wow everybody I'm saying so
now it's just me I'm gonna bring some
people out though like I'm gonna bring
some of my rap homies out I don't know
who but you know it's gonna be lit every
city might be different it's gonna be
different every city